[Music]
there's no cancer national program so
two million less women and girls and do
take part in physical activity in school
across England so this girl can was
actually really about understanding the
barriers that women and girls face to
taking part in any stop physical
activity across across England for Devon
we decided that actually let's do
something about this and we could we
then brought this girl crown to Devon
and worked with lots of partners and
organizations and schools and different
community groups to just embrace the
ethos of this girl camp brings and
that's where then Devon girls can
arrived from naturally the learning from
people to think actually this is
brilliant we really like enjoyed that
communicating with each other and
supporting each other but we want it to
be more local so then that's where
Debbie girls can has their been born
from
[Music]
so active Devin have worked alongside
dermis after college to to help support
them they came up this fantastic project
around to the girls owning actually the
finding the sponsorship to help
incentivize more girls to take part this
the stamp idea around at each time
someone that participates in activity
they get a stamp which then means sort
of prizes so we just supported them by
giving them some funding to be able to
stick start that project and then the
girls from the school that followed em
with Sharla and Kate Hutchins as well
we've just really embraced it along with
the other PE teachers enabled it to
happen yeah so the girls active programs
been running probably for the last three
to four years and Kate Upton's and
myself led on the project initially
started with you sport trust that grew
and grew I grew to a point now where
it's almost out of our control which is
fantastic thing and then we linked him
an active Devon to link it to the devil
girls program that they've got running
back so historically we would have girls
regularly just not bringing in care
having notes and excuses and it was
purely because of how uncomfortable they
felt in the PE kit that we had it's a
lot more so by just changing such a
simple thing to allow them to wear
sports leggins
massively just improve them engaging
from the start the lesson walking in
please it's not the traditional
activities that the girls are desire you
know it's not as I were to them at all
and then a lot of them aren't
competitive they don't have that nature
to them so to create things like booty
baths and yoga and piyo and boot camp
and you know we're doing such a broad
kind of curriculum now it's out
now the girls it was such a choice in
activity so we'll look at them going and
investing and joining the local club or
joining a fitness class just to give
them an idea of what they might like as
opposed to traditional activities
[Music]
because I think has someone I'm not I'm
not particularly confident all the time
I'm how comfortable in myself now back
there and I wanted to help other girls
sort of change as well so from other
girls being unconfident like I was too
confident and willing to sort of do
anything like I am and when I was
approached with the ambassadorship hours
all for it just to try and help other
women and meet other women who've been
through the same journey and see what
they thought I've been in whenever I've
done like sports or exercise I've been
posting on my Instagram with the hashtag
disco can and you know girls like tip
and everything and I've had a couple of
events so I've had a day and Exeter and
there was a bunch of different stools
and there was all of the ambassadors
there I'm something called rock fair and
there was like yoga and all the sub
things you could join in on so I thought
would just run around my friend trying
to advertise you know this go can and
stuff we had like dinner we went to Cafe
Rouge also in Exeter we sort of talked
about what was going to happen and what
had happened with you and the
ambassadorship
I know from speaking with Charlotte and
Kate that they're really keen to see
other colleges and technical schools
taking up this opportunity so it's about
how we can actually now work together to
sort of package it up that actually
other schools can use it's a fantastic
it's an absolute fantastic and the
engagement they've had to spend hundreds
of girls taking part so if we can get
that ready for the next the next phase
that would be brilliant to roll out the
other schools in Devon there's one who
is so not sporty she is the most active
and engaging person that our young
people could have here at South Dartmoor
she is so friendly and bubbly and just
wonderful that she she just has such a
kind nature's heard you know how there
is that kind of person
[Music]
you